Christophe is driving the Volkswagen
Scirocco coupe a created by a towel
design founder Giorgio Giugiaro around
half a million units of the first
edition were built between 1974 and 1980
for VW the Scirocco marked the dawn of a
new era in the late 1960s notes
Christophe all VW models especially the
beetle were starting to become outdated
so Volkswagen decided to blow away the
cobwebs by introducing two new wins the
one was the not quite so powerful but
very solid Passat meaning tradewind it
came out in 1973 and then there was the
hotter and sometimes also store mayor
went the Scirocco and the Italian design
Scirocco dually went down a storm on its
launch critics praised it as the first
in genuinely sporty car in Volkswagens
history the VW Porsche 914 which came
out several years earlier must have
slipped their minds the Scirocco was
kind of a successor to the Karmann Ghia
although the only thing they really had
in common was perhaps the combination of
Italian design and German engineering
otherwise it marked a break with all VW
traditions no rear engine no rear wheel
drive no air cooling instead a
water-cooled front engine and
front-wheel drive the similarity to the
Gulf and Passat is unmistakable with the
classic 70 style Volkswagen features
proudly on display the alloy rims and
abrupt drop off at the back simply ooze
sportiness plus there was a large trunk
tartan style seats and a plastic
dashboard we'll have people now in the
mid 30s getting all nostalgic that's
what cool dad's used to drive
the 1.5 liter four-cylinder engine and
the Scirocco GT delivers a growling 70
horsepower and who designed it georgio
giugiaro exclaims our test driver the
Italian designer created VW's entire new
model family in the early seventies the
Passat the Gulf and the Scirocco and the
form vocabulary with the bull lines and
wedge shape back then that was very much
in vogue Bella machina made in Germany
the Scirocco still has its street creed
no question the Italian crafted body
fits like a glove and the workmanship
and price to performance are typically
for a German car very impressive but
what about the feel at the wheel
front-wheel drive and four cylinders
don't exactly sound like dynamite the
advertising for the Scirocco always
stressed its performance it took some
convincing to market a sports car filled
with front-wheel drive but eventually
people got it a test report from back in
the day says the Scirocco even beat out
the Opel Manta and Ford Capri
what set the Scirocco apart from the
field was its responsive engine and
excellent suspension reviews at the time
called it one of the best handling cars
around
names local P in this bomb estimate and
it really does have a sporty feel
christophe highlights the powerful
engine it's light and above all has a
pretty cool sound the concept of a cool
VW was still hard to swallow in the
early 1970s the Passat developed by Audi
likewise had a struggle to shed its
conservative image but the definitive
turning point came with the Scirocco and
the Gulf launched soon afterwards the
Scirocco was the first modern Volkswagen
developed by VW itself but what makes it
so special is the sum of its parts
sportiness great value for money modern
engineering and of course it's exciting
design its indisputably a landmark in
automotive history the Scirocco showed
that a front-wheel drive car could still
be a joy to drive and doing so it paved
the way for an entire generation the
gulf generation
you